it's not always easy to combine all the
things you clear about into single real
number evaluation metric in those cases
I found it sometimes useful to set up
satisficing as well as optimizing
metrics let me show you what I mean
let's say that you've decided you care
about the classification accuracy of
your cat classifier this could have been
f1 score some of the measure of accuracy
but let's say that in addition to
accuracy you also care about their
running time so how long it takes to
classify an image and caused by our a
takes 80 milliseconds B takes 95
milliseconds and C takes thousand five
hundred milliseconds as 1.5 seconds to
classify an image so one thing you could
do is combine accuracy and running time
into an overall evaluation metric go
into the cost such as moving overall
cost is accuracy minus 0.5 times running
time but maybe it seems a bit artificial
to combine accuracy and value time using
a formula like this like a linear way to
sum of these two things so here's
something else you could do instead
which is that you might want to choose a
classifier that maximizes accuracy the
subject to that the running time that is
the time
take the cosine image that that has to
be less than the equal to 100 or the
seconds
so in this case we would say that
accuracy is an optimizing metric because
you want to maximize accuracy you want
to do as long as possible on accuracy
but that running time is what we call a
satisficing metric meaning that it just
has to be good enough it just needs to
be less than 100 milliseconds and beyond
that you don't really care or at least
you don't care that much so this will be
a pretty reasonable way to trade off or
to put together accuracy as well as
running time and then may be the case
that so long the running time is less
100 milliseconds you users won't care
that much whether there's 100
milliseconds of 50 milliseconds or even
faster and by defining optimizing as
well as satisficing metrics this gives
you a clearer way to pick the quote best
classifier which in this case would be
classified B because of all the ones
with a running time back to 100
milliseconds it has the best accuracy so
more generally if you have n metrics
that you care about is sometimes
reasonable to pick one of them to be
optimizing so you want to do as well as
is possible on that one and then n minus
1 to be satisficing meaning that so long
as they reach some threshold such as
running time stats 100 milliseconds but
some once they reach some threshold you
know you don't care how much better it
is in that special but they have to meet
that special here's another example
let's say you're building a system to
detect wake words also called trigger
words so this refers to the voice
control devices but the Amazon echo
which you wake up by saying a lexer or
some Google devices which wake up by
saying OK Google or some Apple devices
we should wake up by saying hey Siri or
some Baidu devices we should wake up by
saying the only help I do um oh I guess
you want to read the Chinese that's me
how
baidu right so these are the wake words
you use to tell one of these voice
control devices to wake up and listen to
something you want to say and but these
are the Chinese characters for me how
about you so you might care about the
accuracy of your trigger word detection
system so when someone says one of these
trigger words how likely are you to
actually wake up your device and you
might also care about the number of
false positives
so when no one actually said this
trigger word how often does it randomly
wake up so in this case maybe one
reasonable way of combining these two
evaluation metrics might be to maximize
accuracy so when someone says one of the
trigger words maximize your chance that
you device wakes up and subject to that
you have and most one false positive you
know every 24 hours of operation right
so that your device randomly wakes up
only once per day on average when no one
is actually talking to it so in this
case accuracy is the optimizing metric
and the number of false positives every
24 hours is the satisficing metric where
you be satisfied so long as there's an
knows one false positive every 24 hours
to summarize if the multiple things you
care about by said that one of the
optimizing metric that you want to do as
well as possible on and one or more as
satisficing metrics will be satisfied as
long as it does better than some
threshold you can now have a automatic
way almost automatic way of quickly
looking at multiple classifiers and
picking the quote that's one now these
evaluation metrics must be evaluated or
calculated on a training set or a
development set or maybe on a test set
so one of the things you also need to do
is set up training data for development
as well test sets
in the next video I want to share view
some guidelines on how to set up
training deaf and chess set so let's go
into the next video